how difficult was it to say goodbye uh
to data on the first season of book a
card I mean uh uh at this point no it
wasn't difficult I didn't even think I
was going to do it you know it was just
fun to come back and and have another
shot at it uh it was yeah it was you
nervous how many years had it been uh I
don't know 30 years maybe weren't you a
little nervous when I still do this any
or you're like I could just fall back
into this you know I I I didn't know
really if we could still do it but uh
the first day uh I shot was I shot with
Patrick and we were uh on a stage
playing uh Checkers or chess or
something I haven't seen it but uh uh we
looked at each other we go this is both
very strange and not strange at all all
at the same time yeah it felt very
natural and this third season of Picard
of working with all my friends again
people ask you know was that un weird or
strange or difficult or it wasn't it was
you know it was very easy because we we
know each other really well we're all
friends that's what Jonathan says it was
important for me to believe that you
guys just all really enjoy each other
yeah you travel together to do cons or
you do uh you know a cruise and you do
whatever you have lunch or we just talk
on the phone or we you know we see each
other it's that easy instead we don't
get sick of each other no not at all was
there any one person that you can't
mention that was a pain in the ass that
you don't talk to that much yeah
no no not at all uh to a person we're
all friends and that's kind of great
yeah
I love that do you love being directed
by Jonathan very much uh primarily
because he's a very good director uh but
we do have a second hand I mean a
shorthand sort of thing you know what he
wants so a guy got it I got it I know
what you want exactly right and uh
that's that's nice and I'm comfortable
with him and he's comfortable with me
and so yeah I love working with him as
director
um is there anything about this the the
uh stunt that you did that you talked
about in some interview or some that
what that was that terrify that's worth
just talking about briefly well I can
tell you yeah John and that was Jonathan
directing uh because what was he
directing what was it it was uh it was
uh first Contact first Contact yeah and
uh they needed me to there was a scene
where I was on a we were in a missile
silo Patrick and I were and uh Alfrey
Woodard is shooting at us from below and
I say to Patrick I'll take care of this
or I say to Picard or data says to
Picard I'll take care of this and I jump
off the platform and go sailing through
the air down to to the floor where she
shoots me in the chest to no avail right
and uh uh I'm terrified of heights and
even when we were in this missile silo
just standing on the platform I was
terrified uh and Patrick has no fear of
heights so he was bouncing just to you
know make me nervous but anyway
uh the stunt guy did the fall you know
the jump and he jumps through the air
and uh lands on the ground and uh it
looked great and um Jonathan looked at
the dailies and he came to me and he
said uh you gotta do you have to do it
yeah you can tell it's him and I was
like oh God so
what they did was we're in a sound stage
and you know they're very very high and
they rigged me up in a halter and
everything and basically had to take me
up to the top of the Sound Stage and
drop me and uh
so they said we're going to take you up
just a couple of feet so you can feel
what it's like and I said all right so
they took me up a couple feet well I was
ready to throw up at that point that's
you know I don't like I mean for me when
I say I don't like heights I have a
problem with standing uh you know I mean
sitting is semi comfortable I prefer to
be laying down right but uh so I they
took me down and they said how was that
and I went it was horrible and they said
okay we're gonna take it up a little
further so you can see what it was and I
said no no just let's just do it take me
all the way up because I I'll I'll lose
it if you keep doing it increments so
they took me all the way up to the top
of the Sound Stage many many feet and
there was a guy on a catwalk because I
was doing this in the wind uh they took
me spinning yeah yeah so they took a
like I had a pole and straightened me
out yeah so that I would stop spinning
and then they dropped me and uh it you
know the hydraulic kicks in just before
you hit the ground so that it slows down
and um
uh but I got into the right frame of
mind for it I just decided to you know
get into the character just play the
character and and think about my you
know intentions and all that and uh
and I did it and the the crew bursted to
Applause the stunt guys came over and
you know gave me a hat and you know it
was and then Jonathan said I think we
have to do it one more time
but that was oh that was my God and
that's my friend Jonathan